[Music]
one of the biggest problems I read into
it this is really embarrassing to say on
camera was its officially official four
weeks of going vegan are in the books
and I'm so happy I met my goal I have to
thank you guys for challenging me on my
30 days of keto video and we have to
give a huge shout out again to thrive
market for sponsoring this video one of
the biggest problems my patients have in
eating healthy is that it's expensive
and with foods being 25 to 50% off on
thrive market they make it pretty
reasonable to eat healthy whatever diet
you're following you can just click the
category right there on their website
and it pre selects the foods for you so
you don't have to check the ingredients
list and if you click the discount code
below in my description box you're gonna
get 25% off your first order and a free
30-day trial that's pretty awesome if
you're already a member all you have to
do is check your inbox or your thrive
market homepage to see a special offer
for you every single day how cool is
that just to clarify there are many
reasons why people follow a vegan diet
moral ethical environmental but
information I'm going to cover here is
only what's related to nutrition and
health if you want me to talk about
those other concepts I'm happy to do so
drop me a line below it will make us
dedicated vegan video to just that a
vegan diet can be a very healthy diet
whether you're young old somewhere in
between pregnant non pregnant
breastfeeding not breastfeeding
basically it's applicable to all life
stages the reason I put that word can in
there you can follow a vegan diet eat
vegan burgers with sugary sodas with
gummy candies still be vegan and that's
not really healthy right and I have to
say it's not the only healthy diet out
there some of the loudest voices in the
vegan community are quick to say that
veganism is the only healthy option
that's not the case there are several
other healthy diets out there for
example the Mediterranean diet that I'm
personally a fan of that are just as
healthy if not healthier than the vegan
diet I have to be honest and admit that
I don't generally recommend veganism as
my first option I do know that it's a
restrictive diet and we know restrictive
diets have high failure rates plus the
benefits of a vegan diet aren't that
much better than some of the other
alternatives that are simpler to follow
when I recommend a diet I'm trying to
create the healthiest diet but also one
that's feasible and achievable for my
patients to face without disrupting
their lives on the other hand if one of
my patients comes in and wants to follow
a vegan diet I'm totally in support of
that I just have to make sure that
they're adequately planning their meals
they're supplementing when need be
checking their blood tests and ideally
having some guidance either for myself
or nutritionist the research behind
health benefits of following a vegan
diet are substantial and high-quality if
you're following the standard American
diet and then switch over to a vegan
diet you're gonna see improvement in
chronic diseases like diabetes heart
disease strokes even an extension of
life in some cases and what's most
interesting is when we add some animal
products into the mix those outcomes
spill whole truth that's why would I
recommend to my patients is a plant
focused diet meaning that they should
get the majority of their calories from
plants fruits vegetables legumes nuts
seeds healthy fats and a moderate amount
of poultry and fish with a minimal
amount of red meat in fact that's the
diet I follow and recommend to my own
family the field of nutrition research
is ever-changing and as we get more
information more quality studies we
doctors and nutritionists alike are
going to be able to give better
recommendations when it comes to vegan
diet a plan focused diet all of this is
susceptible to change but it's important
that we make the best decisions with the
knowledge that we have on hand the one
thing that I can say with a hundred
percent certainty is there's no such
thing as a miracle diet for everybody
on day one I was excited I was like if I
could tackle Kido I can definitely do
vegan so when all this stuff from thrive
came in I was on boxing I was popping
out the food it looked delicious the
first point at which I had a little bit
of hesitation was when I ordered my
first at home delivery Buffalo
cauliflower bites with some kind of not
real Mayo and this is a wrap with vegan
cheese and unshaken I was having second
thoughts and that's not like me if I set
a goal for myself I'm gonna do
everything in my power to meet that goal
but for some reason when sticking to
this vegan diet I was concerned about so
many things the following week I was
leaving to MIT for the Leadership
Conference I was worried if they're
gonna have vegan options available for
me I was then traveling to Miami for a
few days all these worries started
bubbling in my head and I was really
wondering can I stick to vegan this
entire month why why should i do vegan
more healthy thing you think so yeah but
30 days a long time you just do it one
of the first obstacles I ran into on the
vegan diet was under eating calories now
I'm partially to blame here because I
didn't prep well and even at the opening
of this video I said the healthy way to
follow a vegan diet is to adequately
plan your meals for the first two weeks
I have to be honest I didn't have much
of an appetite I'm not a huge fan of
just eating vegetables and rice and
beans so I didn't have tremendous
portions and because of that I was
calorie deficient I actually noticed
some weight loss what helped me
tremendously to make up this calorie
deficit is eating some of these snacks
that Thrive sent over if I didn't have
these snacks I'd be under eating
calories the majority of the time long
days in the hospital but I got my simple
meals nice background
get me through some rough rough days one
of the biggest problems I read into it
this is really embarrassing to say on
camera the whole plane right I'm sitting
next to a doctor
my stomach is gone had asked him to
stand up like three four times from day
one up until the last day of the diet I
was having tremendous gas and bloating
it's so embarrassing to say I mean think
about this I fly on planes I interact
with patients for long periods of time I
sit in conferences I can't just be
sitting there
flatulent I did try and isolate some
ingredients to see which ones were
causing this gas and bloating
combination for me but I couldn't find
out what it was I normally eat brown
rice I normally eat vegetables and
fruits and beans I expect them to go
away after four weeks but no they stuck
around I would have to say that the
vegan diet probably won't work for me
long term I just can't sit there with my
stomach going and me wanting a pass gas
the entire time what I didn't know about
veganism is that there are a ton of
up-and-coming options for those who
aren't used to eating vegan there are
specialty restaurants that just offer
vegan foods with no animal products that
remind you of foods that you may have
eaten when you ate animal products and I
thought that was really cool on top of
that a lot of these restaurants and even
some of the products I got from thrive
tasted delicious because of the sauces
vegan sauces are on point I'm loving
these wood chips but without some like
sauce like I'm really digging this
primal kitchen classic barbecue sauce
these trips just aren't cutting it
I've talked about on this channel of
decision fatigue because you're
constantly making decisions and you're
using your willpower it's actually a
finite resource what I noticed while I
was following the vegan diet was that I
lost the the drive to go to the gym my
work ethic actually suffered because I
was putting such a strong emphasis on
sticking to vegan when there were so
many temptations and there were things I
wanted to eat I didn't want to hop on my
spin bike in my bedroom I didn't want to
go to the gym with my friends this is
really unlike Mina it's an obstacle I
didn't actually expect to face when I
went to the gym I lifted fine getting to
the gym was the actual struggle at the
time I least expected it
disaster struck I got sick I started
coughing I got a sore throat
I got a low-grade fever I went to see
the doctor I weighed the pros and cons
of starting antibiotics of stopping the
vegan diet I decided to stick with
conservative treatment and treat it like
a viral illness one of my favorite hacks
to treat viral illnesses actually the
symptoms of the viral illnesses is green
tea with manuka honey
[Music]
apparently honey is not vegan what I
guess honey is an animal product but man
I didn't force the bees to make the
honey they make it on their own we
didn't have to milk them for it wait if
you wanted this qualify my 4 week vegan
challenge because I ate honey so be it
[Music]
I gotta say at this point I was rolling
I was starting getting into the vegan
vibe I was trying out new restaurants I
was sampling all the delicious foods
that I got from thrive and I was excited
I was getting close to the finish line
but I will say one of the hardest things
with the vegan diet is peer pressure I
mean when I went out to you with my
friends they were annoyed to say the
least that we had to choose the
restaurant based on my eating
preferences I did do a decent job at
trying to pick out vegan options in not
so vegan places look at this dedication
Greek salad no feta asparagus fries
while I got this next to me
is eating guys what do you need
[Music]
the vegan struggles real honestly I was
really proud of myself and it's nice
every now and then to take a challenge
like this and learn something new about
yourself in fact I want to tell you five
things that I learned not only about the
vegan diet but also about myself during
this process one when I did plan well I
ate very unhealthy when I was at MIT for
breakfast I ate cinnamon toast crunch
with almond milk and a banana every
morning that's not healthy even though
it's vegan - I didn't notice a major
change in my energy level like I thought
I would I mean maybe I had a slightly
decreased energy level but we have to
remember that I was sick in the
beginning I was under eating calories so
I don't feel it's fair to blame vegan
for that three surprisingly I didn't get
weaker on vegan I was lifting strong and
I felt good but what did suffer was
getting to the gym I really noticed the
lack of willpower when I was following
this restrictive diet for when it comes
to my body I lost three pounds
I dropped from 203 to 200 pounds so
there was some weight loss probably from
under eating calories but despite losing
weight I didn't feel as lean I mean all
those sauces all the rice that I ate
pasta that contributed to the carb load
and probably made me feel a little bit
pudgy er than usual five this is the big
one the real difficulty was my GI system
it was a mess the amount of gas and
flatulence and bloating got a camera
it's like grossly to talk about but it
was really bad if you have that with any
diet there's no way you're sticking with
it and I tried taking some
over-the-counter supplements for this it
did absolutely nothing
if you're curious or interested in
starting a vegan diet I don't want to
dissuade you in fact I want to encourage
you go talk to a dietitian nutritionist
physician someone who's well versed with
vegan diets that way you could do it the
healthy happy Safeway without hurting
yourself in the process and please
reduce the amount of refined carbs and
processed foods that you're eating
because as more research comes out
that's the stuff that causes diseases
and shortens your life span now if you
want to check out a really cool playlist
check out my nutrition playlist right
here for some goodies click here and
stay happy and healthy
[Music]